I've done sometimes my parents look at  me like he's having too much fun make  him do something you know discipline  when you they just felt like it was  necessary you do something and then you  do it too fast why did you do too fast  that was always my [ __ ] because if I  told my maid to do something too quickly  my parents were pissed about it I love  the idea that what you guys think that  we went through versus you it's yeah  dirty rocks why you gotta say we I  thought we were on the same team  everyone grew up in America by the way I  said well this chick's just trying to  [ __ ] say my dad made me wash some  rocks he was like that's pretty tight  [Laughter]  by the way that happened to me too oh  you're hanging out at home too much  because then play no my mom would take  off my pants and blow me because she's  just like you're bored oh we should I  should probably suck on your dick  the life like the life that you think I  had is [ __ ] amazing